älter guck mal hier unter leute und da
guck mal hier hoch da oben ist der
letzte gegner erledigt müssen skills und
herzlich willkommen zu einer xxl matt
walsh 64 x 2 folge mit zusammen mit dem
doktor hallo und wir spielen im rahmen
des im rahmen des gamma hd uster events
jetzt hier eine 64 gegen 64 betten haben
wir uns mal dazu durchgerungen das hier
mal auszuprobieren
wir haben unser volk ich bin ins team
zum eisen gegen hat mir alles geholt 12
13 12 übertreibt 15 0 hawkeye ihr bronze
ist bronze gesprochen kann es sein dass
packte mich könnt ihr den typen nicht
ansprechen die sportler vorsichtig sein
legt so unnormal liegt es an mir bei mir
längst auch ich zeig dir abdrücke
passiert einfach ne stunde nichts rolle
der jane trepp ich hasse euch ist
ziemlich hart aussage von ich bin
einfach gerade aus dem boden raus
gelaufen und krieg immer noch bronze
wetter es gibt hier ein großes schiff
für team blau dann die mitte und
dahinter ist normal große schiffe team
rot und es ist 64 gegen 64 ist gerade
ein event auf dem hd werde das spiel
bald geht in die betty und laufen die
treppe hoch und dann in den raum
dahinter
ich dachte es geht die windows mobile
laufen ohne gegen die wand und wird ist
da ja und es lag gerade deftig ich kann
dir 17 alicante sitzen einander nicht
fast 17
deswegen ist es sehr gut hier sehr gut
du könntest du was geben wenn dann
kommen wir dem einwände champions ok
danke ich auch die andere seite
da gibt es für uns aber es ist das
kleine mops diesem denn liebe leute wir
haben uns eine gute strategie ausgaben
zwar werden wir uns jetzt ganz ganz hoch
bauen so von wenn ich erstmal die mit
abgestellten übrig kriegen ja die mit
rang belegen
ich weiß nicht aber dass das halt immer
so ein gemetzel also die runden kann
halt ewig dauern
oder also ich halte ich hatte nämlich
die idee das hat mir dann eben schon mal
probiert diese ich es probiert oben auf
den boden ist die sind jeweils
spinnenweben ja und ich hab die idee wir
bauen uns ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz krass
hoch also 100 lag oder so dann darüber
springen die spinnweben rein wie so ein
fallschirmspringer kommando und dann
greifen wir versuchen wir die von innen
anzugreifen mit acht leute
installations- tod seines lebens sind
verlieren als ordner leider sind die da
oben ein
das bett ist jedoch überhaupt nicht
eingebaut
ob die mitte aber bekommt pro kann dann
ja gut dann komm ich meine mitte wieder
zurück an die windel auf uns reichen
teenager day in the life of dr max die
bauen sich tiefer sturz und krassen
spielers zum motto zins und aufstiegen
wissen
22 in der tasche keine competition
leiden seines next topmodel fällen
erkennt hier kannst du nicht den spruch
kennt ihren leuten ohne technik kein
experte in allen fünf gold bist du noch
anstecken
355 der deren schaden meine ich jetzt ja
kommt ok bauen sich auch da auch wir
machen das jetzt auch die stärke trank
und rhöner weihnacht quatsch das ist
keine chance durchzukommen ist locker
runter geschlagen ich bin da wie viel
von diesem brot schon gekippt sind die
armen schweine leider für eigentlich
ganz leicht gekippt sondern ich hab's
geheimnis ja manchmal nimmt das
tourette-syndrom überhand die konkurrenz
hier im kreis carey die gurke alltag
gary der fettmenge story ein auto wieder
die berichtigen stories von drk ist gab
es ist ich habe immer früher so also
inzwischen durch hörbücher also zb
irgendjemand harry potter vorliest oder
im buch halt es gibt aber auch hörspiele
tasche wenn ja wie blümchen ist und
klassiker kennt bestimmt jeder oder die
drei fragezeichen so das sind für spiele
und ich hatte so 1 das war so ähnlich
wie die ich glaube die tkkg bande oder
wie das heißt dass es so ähnlich wie die
auf jeden fall da gab es eine folge da
ging es um so ein geheimes uran fabry
centro mit so einem spukschloss im
keller
und da hat so ein junger gewohnt mit
seiner mutter und der junge hieß carey
und gary hat aber nicht in diesem
hörspiel geredet so ganz normal sondern
er hat tatsächlich immer so rein gaben
so und ich saß da ein zehnjähriger junge
das war so irgendwie ab acht jahren oder
so das war mega gestört ja ja das kenne
ich aber diese dinge die so ab 8 sind
aber dann einen komplett aus dem leben
reißen
das kenn ich zu gut ja komm mach jetzt
mal eine ansage ich würde sagen bei uns
hoch alles andere das kann es vergessen
damit stärkerer spieler nochmals auf dem
feld aber zwölf gold also wird man ja
das erste mal dass ich in bogen ab in
diesem modus oder machen einfach zwei
bögen oder den vorwürfen fall zu fall
ich habe mich anfang an alles richtig
rund auf der k der sich nur verdrücken
musste zwei scolari 305 mit zwei gold zu
sein ich habe den bogen findet ich weiß
nicht warum ich glaube ich bin die ganze
christenheit dennis rohmann bett einlade
und dann hat das mit
zwar stehen dort man ständig den
punktebesten klasse was ich dir jetzt
den richtigen geber ich habe mindestens
zwei und eins gemacht dass ich der
richtige war erklärte klassischer ego
halt ein einzelkind
dass man intro bald fertig wird okay
hallo kannst du dich bitte aufnahme
konzentrieren ja ich nehme auf das man
in so weit fertig wird die runde ging
voll stehen ja das ist so gut wie es
jetzt in der komfortablen lage dass wir
jetzt einfach alle leute hier abschlags
man unter denen nein was ich hab dich
gesehen würde vorstandes nah als ob da
hat einer den hut
ja ich weiß ich hab sie gesehen würde
vorbestraft ist natürlich fertig wir
fangen jetzt wieder amrum zu schonen den
weg und sein team jetzt abzubauen ist
natürlich richtig lustig ist normal wenn
alien der müssen ich bin heute auch ins
team von längst von wenn so ausgerastet
der läufer unter mir einer den weg
aufgebaut hat habe ich etwas die fassung
verloren
die amisom kassen blieb im pott hat will
ich mir schon ein bisschen model claudia
wären jetzt weg da drüben
ich komm rüber mitarbeiter ums leben
sieben nach rot zeigt mein kompass zu
respektieren
der tag des gedenkens auch noch läuft
können es gibt wenn ja ist dass der rote
ja das ist wenn ein team sein bett
verloren hat dann gibt es hier diesen
kompass an der zeigt an wo die nächsten
mitglieder dieses teams sind dass kein
bett mehr hat ab 1 gegen nice ok sechs
leute noch damit man ihn natürlich
erwischen kann ich sollte vielleicht ein
bisschen es mitnehmen und uns auf die
jagd und fünf gespensterjäger db sind
geben wir den hafen laufen
das ist natürlich geil was du brauchst
du scharf und zu gucken wo die elf kilo
lp achter noch nicht alle checks sollen
so der kompass führt mich hierhin wo zur
hölle ist p-26 blöcke 22
das sondereinsatzkommando zudem ist an
sich schon witzig also das wissen
ziellos der modus wenn kein bett
abgebaut das aber wenn dann deshalb nein
nein das wird viele töten
das motto
bpd vor der nase weggeschnappt federer
meinte über meer locken ist wiederum
blöcke wegziehen gemacht noch vier leute
na wie sieht's aus
heute morgen hatte ich hoffe der eine
heißt rotz sagte der coach aber es ist
eine gute situation darum ich glaube ich
eine der letzten gegner das ist wenn ich
sogar der letzte der 101 hat sich nach
hinten gesteckt oder nach oben auf jeden
fall so ziemlich weg 180 wickelt hallo
hab ich weiß es nicht ich habe ihn nicht
erwischt
wieso wieso kann ich ihnen nicht
wegschlagen
er springt von oben auf mich drauf klar
dann erbitterten gegner ja klar das war
einer von letzten zwei das bei unserer
basecap witze über ich habe meine die
für sie aber ich hab es gibt eine haben
sich jeder ecke leute hoch gebaut bis
zum gehtnichtmehr
einer von denen ist er bräuchte ein
bisschen gold komme ich ein bisschen
gold in der mitte kann man die ganzen
ihren job
beide blöcke weg 163 kinder sind schon
zwei hochbau niveau wenngleich ich
brauch noch ein bisschen ja mal nicht
fünf und ist derzeit ein bisschen gold
leute gucken ob wir die vielleicht den
allerletzten ja noch erwischen du scheiß
misst gestalt läuft bei dir pilzsuppe hd
varianten die übernahme sein
vielleicht ist mit über 138 kommen sogar
gerade spieler oliver olli war du bist
es bei oliver hier sind alle brüder hd
des des richtig in bedrängnis alter das
richtig hart in bedrängnis der typ noch
mal wieso twitter denn kinder wie
michael striegel
die pitot 814 wirklich kommen den ganzen
garten aber jetzt einer bei uns könnt
ihr das ja eigentlich also achten doch
habe ich alles in allem ist der
spielmodus ganz witzig aber es ist ein
bisschen zäh los teilweise am ende läuft
hat ein bisschen wenn sie so dass ich
das finde ich sehr dass kulterer kranken
kindes davor immer so mega sinnlos wenn
alles sich gegenseitig umlegen und
keiner kommt voran
eine heckscheibe meiner wieder hacken
wenn ihm entgegenschlägt sage ich dir
bescheid
okay diese lulu crafter der kann sein
lässt sich immer höher baut ich
langfristig weiter 66
ich weiß nicht wie viel sex wird jetzt
gepflegt wird ist jedoch bis in jedes
spiel an dem von seinem olli da aber ich
rede auch malteser tod und genau jetzt
ist es super beifahrer im sinne von von
wie komme ich jetzt wieder runter ich
bin 1000 blocken über den himmel
okay leute die haben jetzt nur noch bei
der jetzt nur noch ein einzelnen gegner
und erst 163 blöcke entfernen ist jetzt
alle bauen sicher hoch um den zu
erwischen und will jetzt auch hinterher
um den zu holen sagte das einfach auf
die leitung verliebt oder oder wie bei
krieg der welten und tripod einfach mit
so gigantisch langen beinen um
zusammenläuft
ein vermieter 251 kann mich jetzt hier
nicht großartig kann man sich einfach
gehalten
127 blöcke oh mein gott wie hoch ist der
junge alter ich habe die richtige höhe
bin aber von der distanz anderen du hast
die richtige höhe
naja ich finde ich sofort hoch
aber ich bin halt einfach so weiter bot
wieder eine leiter über 20.000 er hat
eine so eine riesen leute junge ist der
alte guck mal hier unter leute und da
guck mal hier hoch da oben ist der
letzte gegner den wir noch erledigen
müssen
das gibt's doch nicht alle blöcke dabei
wie hoch ihr glück ist da ford bringen
es an die leute sich nicht im register
okay leute das gerne
doch der wechsel von den nächsten